before you hit the big time you had to
struggle I said with some jobs sure
regular jobs is this right you were a
valet Parker for a while I used to
professionally Park people's cars yes
okay and let me ask you a question we're
young were you good at that I you know I
would say in terms of I knew how to
drive a car mm-hmm right I knew how to
operate it from yeah oh yeah all the
levers and gears yes you know yeah
there's nothing no you're making no no
we're talking about a mini-sub right no
I I was I was on the d-team of this
valet-parking group I had two costly
errors in my parking Oh my parking
career I left I left the keys to one
person's car in another car as that
party left for the night
so when said other party comes out they
can't find the keys and realize that
they're at someone's house two hours
away so I did that Wow what do they do
how do they fix that why do they fix
that problem they drive two hours to go
get the keys okay all right somehow
figured out not your problem you know my
problem yeah I'm at home with a miller
lite and I another time I took a van
into a parking structure with the
clearance was way too low and ripped the
the luggage rack off the top of it yeah
you seriously damaged in and then
reversed it and there was a lot of
scraping of metal and debris right and
then I just parked the car and hoped the
people didn't come out it was at a hotel
so I hope the guests wait a minute you
didn't go and say anything go away and I
worked the rest of my six-hour shift and
luckily they didn't they didn't come out
I'm just gonna say this were you that
type there's different types of people
there some people that that would have
happened and they would have gone right
to their boss and say I want to make
this right yeah I want to fix this I did
this and this should come out of my pay
yeah are you that kind of guy well I I
would say generally yes but not in this
case no I once got a call this was all
during the summer it was I had big plans
for 4th of July weekend and I got a call
from one of the supervisors who said hey
I got a real opportunity for you to get
off my list
and can you work fourth of July weekend
and you know will forget everything I'm
alright right
no can do I enjoyed my weekend yeah and
who's on top now with my face painting
like a tiger and where are you
supervisor guy call me give me a call
this is the talk this is a great message
that you have do people a career out of
this
coming to this moment and denouncing
that guy don't care about making people
laugh I want to punish that super this
is the long heading biology very nice
you